murphy eight news now nice job
do you remember that movie that's a
pretty woman i just want to be like
vanessa way to go i would never do that
denise and ted i have an idea she said
they do formations i think for our next
evening team photo we do a formation
what do you think all right let's do it
by the way did you guys notice how
vanessa kind of slid into home base
there
that was a heck of a landing i was
thinking she should have gone from that
right to her live shot
so she would have been all in her gear
her hair messed up
that's what i was hoping for but good
stuff all right good job vanessa good
job all right
live look outside right now a beautiful
night tonight in las vegas i'm liking it
temperatures for the day today warmed up
nicely a lot of you've been asking me
hey ted
when's it going to warm up well here you
go we're back to 60 degrees still below
average but at least we've warmed up out
of those 50s
39 again for overnight low we're not
going to see that number overnight
officially
because we have some cloud cover outside
that's going to give a little bit of
blanket
of warmth across the region right now 56
degrees in centennial hills
52 for summerlin 56 for leonte 62 right
now sunrise mountain
in the low 60s for green valley rhodes
ranch and mountains edge at 60 even
57 for henderson 54 for seven hills hey
if you want your name
shout out on tv we do neighborhood shout
outs tell us your name uh your family
and your neighborhoods we'll love to
mention you guys on tv we love our eight
news now watchers
57 and prep 59 for mesquite 66 right now
for laughlin doppler network again dry
conditions we know that
of course was the case these past few
days but we turned on the satellite you
can see the clouds really pushing in
from the west so
we talked about those clouds that were
going to happen later in the afternoon
and
there you go there's those clouds all
coming from that disturbance off the
coast
providing a lot of cloud cover the san
joaquin valley we see those clouds that
will still increase overnight now that
much advertised system that we talked
about
that was going to bring us a chance for
showers and of course some stronger
winds
that looks like it doesn't look as
promising as what we originally thought
as it stays to the north it keeps its
energy up there so we'll get some light
breezes for friday
chance for showers probably not going to
happen here but look at this later on
the week next week
as we approach the weekend we could see
slight chances return
again but that's just still way too far
away for us to
make that call on that so we'll keep our
eye on that for the rest of the week
meanwhile we're also tracking tropical
storm ada
70 mile per hour winds right now you
give four more winds and it's going to
be a category one hurricane it is off
the coast right now
of florida specifically tampa and it
will make its way
on shore over florida and back out to
sea we'll be watching that for these
next few days here's your forecast
overnight temperatures 45 degrees
mostly cloudy skies they'll stay cloudy
in the morning then we'll see sunshine
the afternoon 64 degrees and warmer for
tomorrow
light winds still around for tomorrow on
your seven-day forecast
with your weekend clearly in view
looking good for the weekend last
weekend all that rain this weekend not
bad at all mid 60s high
60s next week even warmer in those mid
70s
brian back over to you